Jim Acosta was sitting 10 feet from me
and he badmouth me saying I was a PR
stunt abut that I did that he played me
directly a PR stunt you get to promote
my pillow here's what happened last week
so we got a little rerun here I mean I
never thought that my popular theme
could go any bigger you know whatever
infamous babe whatever you want to call
it but I start making masks I converted
my whole company 75% over to make a
cloth mask and it was quite a project we
had to trade all employees but we did it
in lights for gays can you just explain
a little bit about how you do that I
mean did you have to bring in like
experts to change machines I mean the
call I made a call to the vice
president's office I actually an email
and they sent me right away - Peter
Navarro and and whatever he was running
I didn't know Hopi turnaround was and
then he emailed me right back and he
directed me to a task force they'd
already set up and a little coalition
about anybody that was all these
different things from Mass together or
whatever kind of like let's set this up
so people can have their questions
answered so I called them the first
question I said one of the one of the
measurements is there a restriction that
I have to know about because obviously I
have to worry about getting sued by
frivolous lawyers in California let's
not forget that so I had to make sure
everything was you know was right in the
meantime I already said I'm doing this
so Mike my employees they're very good
at scaling I've had some of the same
team we're like a big family we just
started going we took their sewing
machines moved him made him eight feet
apart
we had to um had to move racking we had
to make sure that I had to make sure
that we had the right fabric it was a
blessing but my pillow fabric was
perfect for it we just had to not do two
processes of printing another thing so
we had to do a different process but it
wasn't a big switch and then I had to
get elastic at first I bought the wrong
elastic it had latex so I dumped that
get the right elastic there was a low
shortage for one day but I was
determined I was going to get it and
then we we had a big
really expensive cutting machines so we
can cut the patterns and we were up and
making masks in three days
everyone was training there and there I
made like close to 10,000 the first day
and we added two shifts a friend of mine
we lot of them had to be laundry as a
commercial ornament we just I was up til
12:00 every day setting the foundation
this till midnight starting again at
5:00 in the morning well then I get an
email from the vice president's office
and said could you come out to the and
be involved in a roundtable like I was
involved in one in 2017 first time I was
ever in the White House and for me to be
in America
well they said and we'd like you to help
raise some remarks I'm gonna okay they
got half a track going I'm going what do
I need remarks for a roundtable for so I
actually the remarks are here these are
the typed ones here these are the type
remarks okay so I type him up and send
him out there and I was even real
particular they wanted remarks of what
we were doing and pretty specifically
about what my pillow was doing I'm going
okay I don't really you know that's fine
I don't they need to brag about what I'm
doing to help the country but I'll do it
you know did sits in a roundtable and so
I fly out there we get to the roundtable
and there's all the five CEOs or that
are there the vice-president a couple
guys down at the end I forget who they
were and we go around the table and he
swung on this one's doing respirators
and and this one's and I said we're
doing masked and but I wasn't looking
nobody was looking at their remarks or
whatever they didn't even see any papers
on and I'm going send that the president
came in and this is a good half-hour of
everyone saying what they're doing you
guys what you know what can you make
more you know what do you plant what are
your plans and and we get tired of the
president gets up and they all get up
and he said to the vice president we
didn't read our remarks he goes oh no no
they were outside the president might
call you up to them down really slow
down but we go into the other room
towards the Oval Office and the
president he's showing it all the CEOs
here kind of get a little mini tour here
and then he sits down he's got to read
his speech with the vice president and
we're sitting over here at this table
and I thought you know what I read the
remarks like you know what I want to
give a message
hope to the people and so I start
writing on the back and you know if you
can see my scribbles there's little
arrows that go down and stuff yeah we
wrote it I thought I would rewrite it on
a clean piece of paper I just get done
with the last thing I mean there's
crossed out and everything and they go
ok we're going out to the Rose Garden
and I'm going what the brothers okay so
I all I said was God please let me read
my writing the president calls me up
first I mean I came right up we do
practices so I didn't know we were all
gonna go around the end so he called me
up first and I went straight up so I
think they held the other CEOs back so
it's just him and I and here's a guy
that has so much nervousness of speaking
now I did have my um my throat I did I
had vocal cord surgery just a week
before so I was a little recipe like I
am now and and I get up there and I read
them and then I just felt you know let
it go turn around I said you mr.
president you mind if I read something
off the cuff no he said yes and then I
read the guy you know God gave us grace
on November 18 or November 8 2016 you
know I just read that they don't talked
about that we are the nation had turned
his back on God and we should spend this
time animal you know reading the Bible's
getting back on the word and spending
time with our families and I said we're
all gonna get through this with this
great administration and everybody's
prayers and everybody combining we're
all in this together and we're gonna be
stronger and safer than ever you were to
think I shot some okay so so you do all
this it's impromptu he's letting you do
your thing you talk about God you're
making I think at one point you were
making 50,000 masks a day right yeah you
do it doing that right now so you finish
you finish the speech and did you even
think about it or realize what was about
to come your way like did it even cross
your mind no do you know what it was
just it was like to be if didn't feel
like you know it wouldn't I didn't think
it'd be a shot heard around the world
and we won't we went back into the way
and the first inkling I got that it
might be real big was the vice-president
came to me and he goes he was just wild
like you know because you've opened up
that you know opened up the heavens and
these people are gonna you know you're
just it was just I don't even remember
what he said but he was just I could
just tell he just loved it I'm good I
got a little confirmation that it was
okay you know the president never said a
thing about it you know he was talking
to the CEOs and us and and we go except
when I when I left the White House I
finally you got my phone back see they
have your phones right and I go open up
my phone and turn it on
I had 750 text messages I didn't know
that many people had my phone number
what happened I looked at Twitter in
there thousand I looked at my piece book
it had blown up I have 2,000 emails I
mean it was just and I'm trying to drive
and get to em going well I had to pull
over
I was just gone I call them friends they
go what happened they go don't you know
everybody's talking about it I'm gone
really and so for that point I've done
80 some interviews as of today every day
all day I've gotten calls from Israel my
friends in Australia they said it was on
top of all the news in the time on paper
was the cover of their national paper
this was like you'd think it was and you
know one of the good things there's
there I'm glad I asked the president
because the everybody knew he had no
idea you know he had no idea so you know
people that said oh you're mixing church
and state or churching out or whatever
gotten got enough government you know
what I did that so what are you gonna do
put me in jail sorry
right well you didn't you also didn't
the government didn't force anyone to
listen to you people could either hear
you and and and believer enjoy what you
say or not so be it
but now okay but now talk about just the
the media reaction because I'm sure
you're getting a lot of love from from
nice quarters and it must be nice to
hear the vice president say some nice
things but really I mean I you know I
was watching it as it happened on
Twitter and the amount of of main stream
media people who've never don't
a dollar given up any of their time
they're all the my pillow guy mocking
you mocking Trump for bringing you on
it's a big stunt blah blah meanwhile
you're the one I mean it cost you you
don't have to tell me how much but I
assume it cost you quite a penny to
convert the operation not only that but
what you're then not making in pillows
for just speaking out his name because
now when that happen everybody you know
we have laid off a bunch of people that
were on the road doing home shows I have
90 some people that do home shows and
fairs like I used to do they have lost
their jobs because they were closed at
my stores were closed well now they
could all get they could all get on
phone the calls are still coming in and
but if you get on phones now and with
our business went up like you say for
everyone attack nine people it's even
more than I think for everyone attack
fifty people would go after that guy
what's wrong with you you know I mean
they would tell that guy what's wrong
with you he's doing great things what
have you done and these hosts on MSN Jim
Acosta was sitting 10 feet from me now
and he badmouth me saying I was a PR
stunt abut that I did that he played me
directly a PR stunt to get to promote my
pillow are you kidding maybe you did
listen right Jim I was promoting Jesus
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell